hello today we're going to continue our
series talking about how to counter
aggressive openings So today we're going
to talk about the fried liver attack
this is a very common opening especially
at lower levels and I'm going to show
you a really fun way to counter it and
have some fun yourself so the fried
lever starts after E4 E5 Knight F3 we
defend the pawn bishop C4 and for
starters we can actually avoid the fried
lever right away
by playing Bishop to C5 instead of
Knight to F6 because what this does is
it keeps this queen attacking that G5
Square so the Knight can't come to G5
just yet and then if they support this
G5 square with the bishop and now they
want to play Knight G5 we could just
play a move like Knight to F6 and after
Knight G5 we castle and this Rook is
going to be protecting that F7 pawn and
our King is perfectly safe we're not
really worried about any sort of
sacrifices like this because the two
pieces um are going to be more important
because they're working towards the
center they're playing a bigger part in
the game than the rook and the pawn
because in this position white sacrifice
they're active and developed bishop and
knights for a rook and a pawn so we just
have a massive development advantage and
we could just play D5 continue our
develop
black should be very happy here so if
you want to just avoid the fried liver
altogether you could just play Bishop to
C5 but uh we're going to talk about
after Knight to F6 Knight
G5 here really the only move is D5 this
is the only way to really defend the
square because white is attacking it
with both the Knight and the bishop and
a move like Queen E7 just doesn't work
because um you don't really want to
after either piece takes back back you
don't really want to take with a queen
here um so you're stuck down upon and
without castling
rights so again the only way to defend
this is D5 and after D5 um white usually
plays e takes D5 because this is like a
poison Pawn black can't actually play
Knight 6 D5 at least just yet because if
we did white would play Knight takes F7
sacrificing the Knight to draw our King
out and deliver this double attack on
the knight and king and the only way to
defend it would bring our King further
into the center into kind of unshielded
territory uh where it's going to be very
weak and and white can just have a lot
of fun here with this king of the center
continuing to put pressure on our
position
so again taking this Pawn is really not
a good idea instead here the main line
um goes Knights A5 and this is solid you
can definitely play this um there's
nothing wrong with it whatever but I'm
going to show you a fun line instead of
that called the Yad Gambit and that's to
play B5
here B5 is just absolutely ridiculous
like our piece is attacked they just
want a pawn and we're just attacking
their Bishop we're just like doing
something different alog together and
this looks so weak and so crazy but
there's actually a lot to it there's a
lot of ways that W can go wrong here so
first off if they just continue with
what they wanted to do and then take on
C6 we're going to take on C4 and say you
know White Castles or something um we're
doing quite well here because um we have
this Pawn in the center and white
doesn't have any Pawns in the center on
top of that we have two Bishops in a
position that's very very open there's
not a lot of Pawns standing right in
front of each other like closing the
position off so these two Bishops are
going to feast in this position so black
would be very happy with a position like
this where white takes that
Knight so instead of that this is just a
free Pawn like white can just play
Bishop takes B5 and that's a very
reasonable thing to do that's what
you're going to see a lot of the time
it's played in 63% of Club level games
and after this move Black's already
equalized black has a pretty great
position here and there's still a lot of
tricks left so after Bishop takes B5
Rock's going to play Queen takes
D5 now what this does is because the
bishop was no longer defending D5 we're
free to take it and we're also attacking
the bishop on B5 and the pawn all the
way on G2 so this is a very annoying
threat so even though we're down a pawn
we're probably going to win a pawn
back so if white was really greedy and
they saw this double attack and they
wanted to just keep everything tidy keep
their material they play Bishop to F1 a
very very passive move setting the
pieces back up for the next
game it I mean it's not great but I
could see someone doing this and in
response we could already play a move
like Bishop
C5 and then if white just makes a
natural move of attacking Our Queen
they're already much much worse because
of the devastating Bishop takes F2 so we
sacrifice the bishop to draw the king
out and then we
check and it doesn't really matter where
this King goes it's going to cause
problems so if the King goes back to E1
there's Queen to H4 check which is a
double attack again and taking advantage
of this undefended Knight on G5
and then if the King goes to
E2 we can go for a different plan Play
Bishop to G4 developing a piece with
check and we're also skewering the king
and the queen so the king is not going
to move because they would just lose um
a queen but instead if they play Knights
F3 now this Knight is pinned it's
self-pinning and we play E4 to take
advantage of that pin
piece White's position is just terrible
this king's in the center it's going to
be very hard for him to develop and
we're one move away from having our
Brooks connected so black is doing
fantastic
here so that's kind of how things can go
wrong for for white really quickly if
they just try to hold on to their
material like that so really they don't
have much options um besides giving them
T back and they can do that in a few
different ways um Bishop takes C6 is the
most common move here and after Queen s
C6 um what has a few options white can
Castle White can play Queen to
F3 um let's just see what happens after
Castle seems like a natural move right
just getting the king out of the center
potentially trying to take advantage of
our King in the center um but we can
actually develop very quickly and it
gives us a lot of um very quick
counterplay so first we can play Bishop
to
B7 and what this does is creates a mate
in one threat with Queen six G2
so if you're playing like a bullet game
where your opponent's not paying
attention that's that's you know a good
threat to have um and white only has one
good way to deal with it and it's not
very common it's only playing 177% of
games so that means like 83% of the
games from here black is just completely
winning just like game over winning
because white typically plays a move
like
F3 and then Black's going to give this
check
Bishop C5 check King goes to the corner
and here just look and appreciate
Black's Bishops they're just slicing
through the position just dominating the
center and wreaking havoc on on White's
position so after this uh we really just
want to continue to open up these
Bishops even more so after something
like this we want to play G5 followed by
G4 taking advantage of the fact that
they can't take because the bishop and
the queen line up on that G2 Square
creating that mate threat we saw before
and this is just devastating for black
we're going to Castle long so we have
even more fun on the on the king side
just launching our pawns down the board
maybe we can get our Rooks involved all
of our pieces are happy and creating
threats against that white
king so again very scary stuff White's
best move here instead of F3 um would be
to do something like Queen to F3 even
Knight to F3 is actually quite bad
because after this um we have some
options here I think the simplest is
probably just a castle long and uh again
all of Black's pieces are are doing
fantastic and we have this pin so the
Knight can't take on E5 um so very crazy
position but a very fun one at that so
um Bishop takes C6 isn't really that
problematic um we can have a lot of fun
there um but Knight to C3 is a different
move which
uh perhaps is a little bit more logical
because it both defends the bishop and
attacks Our Queen and develops piece so
you know does a lot in one move makes a
lot of sense and here they dealt with
this threat but they didn't deal with
the other threat so we're just going to
take that pawn and after this move we
are threatening both The Rook
and kind of the Knight on G5 although
the Knight on G5 is not really hanging
because this queen is also tied to our
Knight so that was one of the downsides
of moving our B Pawn is now this Knight
doesn't really have any
support but on the other hand we could
bring this bishop to the B7 Square on
this really nice long Diagon so there's
pros and cons here again we only has one
move to
stand a chance here to not be like
completely busted and that is Queen to
F3 because Queen to F3 just kind of goes
into an end game where things are very
calm solid black is still perhaps
slightly better there um but the idea
again is the queen is protecting this
Rook on H1 and the Knight is protecting
the
queen and a move like Queen takes G5
just loses um to Bishop takes or queen
takes on C6 so that's no good um we have
to trade the Queens but again just like
I said black is slightly better here
black is doing perfectly fine we just
have to break this pin because white was
threatening Knight 6 E5 and after this
uh you know Play Bishop D6 we could
Castle King side probably even Castle
long we got a lot of options it's very
flexible but I think all of our pieces
again are going to be quite happy um and
if we could bring this Knight to D4 that
would also be great um in C2 um it's a
really double-edged position so even
though it's an end game I still feel
like it gives us great winning
chances so a lot going on here in this
position we looked at Knight to C3 we
looked at Bishop F1 we looked at Bishop
takes C6 and just like I said black is
already equal if not better here I think
practically it's already much worse or
harder to play from whid um but just to
show how you would counter this if you
were white here white really only has
one move that gives them a very
significant advantage and that is Bishop
to
F1 so personally I don't think a lot of
people are going to play that move I
think that's a very strange move to play
especially especially if you don't know
this line I don't know how you would
think to play Bishop F1 the idea is
essentially um instead of having your
Bishop out in the open where it's going
to be attacked the bishop is just going
to come back home where it's going to
protect the G2 Pawn so after a move like
Queen 6 D5 um we can counter this by
playing Knight to C3 with Tempo
attacking the queen and then the Queen's
a little bit uncomfortable it can't take
on G2 which is the main point and then
after it moves white can take on B5 and
again this Knight is a little loose
because we don't have this B Pawn to
support it and White's quite happy here
so this is the the one downside of this
line um you have to be willing to go
into this there's some pros and cons
this line but I think there's a lot more
Pros than cons especially if you can
surprise your opponent with this
weapon one last thing I'll mention if
your opponent goes Bishop to E2 instead
um there's really only one good move
here if we play Knight takes or S if we
play Queen takes D5 we run into a
similar issue where Knight to C3 is very
annoying and after Queen takes G2 um our
Queen is actually not in a great spot
here because Bishop to F3 comes again
defending the rook and we we can take
this but they're going to take our
Knight with check and winning our Rook
so that was kind of fast but the bottom
line is we can't really take on um G2
because the bishop is going to come and
take advantage of this weak
Knight um so after Knight to C3 white
would be doing quite well so we don't
want to take on D5 um instead of taking
on D5 we're actually going to play
Knight to
D4 um and what this move does is it just
defends this B5 Pawn gets rid of this uh
loose piece on C6 and brings it to a
more Central and active Square where
it's going to cause um some problems for
white so after Knight F3 if white were
to just
Castle we can really just play any move
here we can um just develop and castle
and we will be doing quite well all of
our pieces have nice nice squares again
and this Pawn on D5 is uh it's going to
be gone very soon there's no way for
white to really hold on to it if they
ever play Knight C3 um we always have
this B4 move in our back pocket to kind
of remove the defender of this Pawn we
can always play Bishop B7 as well um so
a lot of ideas here to to win back this
Pawn um and I I again think this is a
really fun position where both sides
have some um chances but I think black
is going to have a lot more fun and it's
going to be a lot harder for white to
play so again to recap after Knight to
G5 we play D5 again it's pretty much
forced but after white takes we play
this move B5 gambiing a pawn and having
a really fun game following
so thanks for watching if you have any
questions list them down below and I'll
see you in the next video